So, as I said,
I'm starting to learn more about this concept.
So these are the books that I'm going to be reading.
It's gonna take me a while to get through them,
but we are going to learn together.
Um, the living goddesses who cooked the last supper,
women's history of the world before war,
on marriage, hierarchy,
and our matriarchal origins,
when god was a woman,
and societies of peace. Matriarchs past,
present, and future.
In my last post, a couple people called me out,
rightly so, on the fact that
I kind of made it sound like matriarchy was just opposite patriarchy,
and that I know is not true.
I know it's a completely different system
that values community care above,
like, a hierarchical structure.
But again, this is something that I'm just starting to deep dive into.
So if you wanna deep dive into it with me,
um, those books are where I'm starting.
If you have other book recommendations,
I would love to take them as well.